freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge eintrag persönlicher koch
heute wird ethisch mario ist nämlich in
köln und wir haben sonne lange
geschrieben lange gefragt ihr habt mich
unendlich oft gewünscht und heute ist es
soweit ich bedeute einen tag eher
wahllos persönlicher komme ich freue
mich schon sehr dass er gleich kommt und
ihn kennenzulernen
aber wir müssen natürlich mit dem
wichtigsten anfang dem essen alles wird
dann ein bisschen anders
manche leute wünschen sich von mir keine
ahnung
selbstgebackenes focaccia zum frühstück
größeren viktor die wahl wünscht sich
van hoven teilt pancakes ich habe ich
seitdem ich selbst ein bisschen kopf
kann man immer noch keinen text sondern
klassische selbsthilfe auch immer crew
ich habe ein bisschen was mich aber ich
kann nur so viel sagen das ist sehr sehr
einfach alles wir haben alles
vorbereitet was wir brauchen wir haben 4
400 gramm mehl 400 milliliter milch ihr
versteht schon und auch ein 100 gramm in
100 milliliter milch also gegeben
zunächst mal unser 400 familie hinein
und normal klassischen pfannkuchen
sollte man einfach keine wissenschaft
daraus machen finde ich persönlich hoffe
sie schmecken die man natürlich dann
auch dann geben wir unsere eier dazu
jetzt stecke ich die eier mal kurz an
zack zack zack zack zack das ist kaputt
geht unsere milch kommt dazu ein
bisschen erstmal und wir wollen das
ganze herunter und heute weil ich so im
entferntesten winkel in meinem kopf
irgendwie drin habe ein kleiner schluck
sprudelwasser ich weiß dass es
vielleicht komisch aber meine oma hat
das glaubt immer so gemacht und zwar
jetzt so wenig dass sie keinen
unterschied machen würde deshalb ja ich
mache mir dazu weht schon zum schöner
klumpen freiheit teig die games in
unsere fahne ein wenig öl lassen das
heißt werden also wir backen jetzt
unseren pfannkuchen öl in der pfanne
wir verteidigen das hier ein bisschen
und den rest macht man dann über so eine
schwenkbewegung muss man schnell sein
bevor alles an bach ein großteil der
fälle benetzen wir machen die panne
nicht zu heiß und machen das ganze jetzt
ist es durch freunde schublade komplett
nasenbluten bei ich finde die nicht
besonders hübsch um ehrlich zu sein
vielleicht habt ihr bestes rezept als
meint dachte irgendwie das würde
funktionieren
ich hab mal ein probiert also schmecken
tun sie schon aber es ist
ein bisschen werden nicht so schön braun
das ist schon fast eher so ein bisschen
richtung tir na ja ich werde gleich
einfach richtig viele täler rein machen
und dann hoffen dass es ihm trotzdem
schmeckt oder hier seht schon unser
erster angekommen
aber ich muss durch viele sagen ich
mache und ich hoffe dass sie trotzdem
schmecken der ja echt war zuerst ein
stehen wir sind jetzt auch schon das war
damals zweiter wollen wenn ich mal zu
wir sind mediationen klammert sich nach
den gruppen kommen erst jetzt nicht
läutet ich freue mich den erste bank
open weg was nicht höher
was ist deine story zu also warum kuchen
gesagt er fand ich gut geworden
ich finde dass ich jetzt nicht mehr so
hoch wie früher
oberfranken raum fanden also meine fans
meine mutter zehn mal kuchen
zimmermänner genau was mit kann die
verbreitung des wagens fuhr 2011 los
doch ein zuckerguss überzogen mit zucker
gegessen ich weiß gerade ist das ein
erstes video com arbeitet in spanien den
ersten bisschen kann man ihn auch dann
wirst du alles auf sich wirken und erst
dann kommen wir zu bewerten
deutlich dass du hier schon schmecken
wirklich lieben und hassen von britney
besonders aber läuft et also ich finde
es ganz ganz ehrlich es ist eine pure
genuss
es ist wirklich ich habe noch immer
recht auf ist hier die rede ist es
verdammt speichellecker das gefällt mir
sehr gut aber ich muss wahrscheinlich
110 machst du so gar nicht bis zehn
genau das ein bisschen ich will das ist
absolut meckern auch richtig denn in der
haube aus bittet ich muss sagen sie sind
bisschen zu dick bis zu 460 geäußert
jetzt natürlich dass lothar kramm
gleichen modells noch irgendwas noch
nicht drin die machthaber seine lieben
aber es könnte etwas essen würde ich
sagen sie zum 915 ist schon richtig
ratschlag
aber wenn ich ein bisschen dünner hätte
man ja so und heute und sehen sagt für
die schuhe richtig stand und das finde
ich echt gerade weil ihr habt es war
gesehen die waren so ein bisschen die
sind so ein bisschen irgendwie so
thalmann und ja ich bin doch mal was du
kannst das ist schon auch gut aber
gerade durch die auch ein spanngurt da
war das noch dass so etwas gehört habe
aber dadurch dass die unter oder
zwischen den zwei tellern wann ist also
ein bisschen feuchtigkeit und jetzt
finde ich die auch geil aber ich bin
mega profil neun von zehn
ich hoffe und ich denke ich werde dich
nicht noch mehr überzeugen können im
laufe des tages die küste nicht
erreichen die kabel drauf auf jeden fall
wir sehen uns erst mal mittagessen hier
kommen zum mittagessen nicht mehr
gespannt ob es jetzt schon jemand
erwarten kann wenn man das sich diesmal
selber an dass die da oben gerade
alabama ist es ein bisschen komisch
filterkaffee so ich gedacht was die
gäste wollen und manche leute sagen halt
machen wir mal bitte seeteufel weg
hinauf süßkartoffel zürich hatte ich
auch schon ab und du hast hier offen
spielerisch das ist der legen täter
nudelauflauf von montana tech day ist
nicht der nächste härtetest wieder
hinauf rechtzeitig möglich ist so gut
der käse würden gezogen und ist es
einmal nach hause das hab ich mir
gedacht dass der kaffee ist wenn du es
dir wünschst aber ich habe zwei drei
sachen das extra gemacht die manche
nicht so macht wo ich mir denke das ist
das noch ein bisschen besser machen wir
legen uns so willkommen also erst hier
hinten ein topf mit nudelwasser auf
heute sagt uns ein video das die nur
einen drittel sollen wir machen alles
nach rezept wie man hier hilft mir sehr
beim schneiden die haben da eben auch
schon das zweite frühstück für dein
video grad sehr kühl damit den herren
ist arbeit geschlafen und das hat so ein
ding ich stelle jetzt groß ich versucht
kleiner stein sagte mann du kannst es
nicht es geht und trägt ja keiner weise
trägt eigentlich willst du einen teil
hinten dran weil dann fällt es halt
zusammen
außerdem ist ein messer schneidet
sowieso reederei flashbacks oft durch
sein da wurde ja auch gesagt werden so
hören dann wieder oder aktuelle stücke
so verstauen von anfang an seitdem ich
das von mannschaft gab es wirklich ultra
viele leute aus leider community die mal
bei mir kommentiert abwehren
ich sehe was die leute wollten sie ist
fertig und wir können ein bisschen zu
den groben dreck somit c war so ein
bisschen ab machen aber an sich sind die
eigentlich schon relativ sauber sagte
schneider den sprung ab es ist einfach
so entscheidend wie zu beobachten denn
überhaupt echt so alles über die ganze
noch nicht mal ein bisschen schwein
sie sollte sich zweimal habe zudem schon
selbst gemacht wenn irgendwann mal ganz
ehrlich so das hackfleisch ist jetzt
richtig auf temperatur und der top-werte
eben schon fast ein bisschen braucht
habe ich noch ein bisschen russland wir
braten das ganze jetzt richtig
damit läuft nach oben bilden weil die
gehen natürlich ordentlich macht ja den
man sieht schon dass hat jetzt irgendwie
zum farbe gekommen und jetzt ihr fremden
breite noch ein wenig vor wie man so
etwas auch in seinem video sonst sie
werden alles schön angelastet ist dann
mag das ganze ein bisschen klein und
brate es jetzt nochmal so krise nicht an
irgendwelchen liter wasser
kaum eine branche hat auch genug das
einzige was mir gedacht habe heute
montag so geriebenen kommentare ich
meine klar wir arbeiten jetzt auch mit
einer magie tüte aber wenn man die
möglichkeit hat sollte man käse selbst
rein weil ich weiß nicht genau was das
für mitte ist aber der käse klebt ja
nicht in der verpackung und das ist halt
ein zusatzstoff und wenn man es selbst
bleibt hat man das nicht dabei ist immer
ein bisschen besser und frischer man bei
so was gehen kann so besser ist es auf
jeden fall
wir können schon eine käse rausholen
also ich dachte mir ich probiere ein
paar bestandteil abzugleiten also
büffelmozzarella statt normal mozzarella
emmentaler dann noch ein wenig rekord
als extra und mein ziel ist ja es besser
zu machen als du es bisher gegessen hat
[Musik]
so sollten wir gehen jetzt die zwiebel
hinein dürften die indessen mit an
so jetzt ist ja alles
unsere waffe gegen kopf- bauch- und dann
gehen wir jetzt dazu einen liter wasser
lassen das ganze noch einmal aufkochen
dann kommt jetzt dazu unsere
gewürzmischung 2 packung solche triple-
spüren wir auch unter und das kriegt
schon eine sehr charakteristische farbe
gucke ich mir diesen mann der hier
gerade mit 400 gramm im tal auch noch
weg ja ich bin echt sehr leckere auch so
ich schneide jetzt den bildschirm
zarella hinschreiben und man merkt
direkt ist natürlich ein bisschen
weicher das sich genau mit der
normalgewichtigen finde ich auch gut
durch den winter machen echt schäfer
sind wo ich bereite jetzt einfach mal
die gesamte station fort da sehen wir
uns wenn wir das zusammen bauen also
wenn man eine lage nudeln auf den boden
da haben wir hier unsere magie tüten
mischung
das ist ja auch gut auf das ist ja genau
das einzige was ich mir gemacht gemacht
habe ist das ein bisschen länger
eintauchen zu lassen
und ich habe sage nochmal oft habe ich
tepper und celli ein bisschen art
gewürzt damit dass noch ein bisschen ein
bisschen mutiger ist das ganze da geben
wir jetzt mal zwei drei lagen drauf es
ist ja irgendwohin zusammengelegt gewürz
einfach das kommentiere ich auch selber
noch und das stimmt genau das meine ich
mir auch immer neuer darf ihr erstes
einer closed schichtkäse das team
großartig grieben clusters ist der
nächste rekord wir machen ja so zwei
drei kleckse reporter ein bisschen
zwischen sinn einfach so für diesen
italienischen tat schon immer so ein
bisschen reporter ist natürlich auch
immer guten lasagne immer ein fester
bestandteil auf seelische nächste lage
käse dann machen wir noch eine dritte
gleich mit rezeption
jetzt machen wir ein klein wenig so hast
du noch überhaupt nicht mehr so
ordentlich wie bei den anderen weil es
gibt natürlich feuchtigkeit wir wollen
das ist auch knusprig wird das perfekt
auf jetzt kommen wieder käse drauf 400
gramm käse kommen komplett rein und wenn
ich fertig werden soll sie nicht umsonst
gesehen haben und dann kommt auch
unserer büffel mozzarella den verteilen
wir schön gleichmäßig obendrauf der wird
so schön denn wer zieht sich so richtig
wenn er geschmolzen ist ein wenig frisch
geriebenen grappa dann oben drüber
das wird es so schön knusprig machen so
gut aus oder es kommen wir jetzt in
unseren backofen rein für 35 minuten und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wenn es fertig
ist
[Musik]
und fahrradweg nudelauflauf hoffentlich
optimierter form nie sagen ich mach' dir
jemand schild achtung nicht nachdem
schönes stück mal raus wer jetzt schon
ein bisschen abgekühlt ist auch wichtig
dass man noch ein bisschen kühlt dadurch
setzt er sich nämlich ein bisschen und
zerfällt nicht so direkt kokettieren
eigentlich hast du super hinbekommen
osterfest ihr kennt mich war es okay die
hand
ich sage mal die leute sollte nicht zu
viel werden zuerst berichtet hatte wäre
gleich und aufgegessen so deutlich sage
euch ehrlich iran iw die ganze zeit
schon während der rede schon die ganze
zeit vor sich hin ich schmeiße aber die
kann man zwar noch nicht ganz leer aber
eigentlich möglich dass ernsthafter
krise ist perfekt bewusstseins noch ein
bisschen gefehlt hat war ja meist und
hast du auch noch packen
das ist ja so leicht noch die kopfhaut
an gemacht sodass hat das plaza jetzt
lerne ich so leicht da ist ne die nur im
doppelpack das eingeflossen sich auf
gesorgt hätten wir diese sachen alle
auch ich werde ich dich küssen wenn ich
habe viel auf das ist richtig lecker
also in c von c das ist eine einzige
roman ist so gut dass ich mache mich
schon gut
also ich noch einen extra zutaten ein
bisschen teures wirklich schade ist denn
jeder wird sein geist er ist wirklich
das ganze passiert hier auf einem typen
produkt dafür ist es wirklich kranken
kranker und ich freue mich dass es zehn
aus dir raus und natürlich der email in
dem schmecken wird versuchen man kann
nur so viel sagen das abendessen vor
wird hoffentlich dem ganzen noch die
krone aufsetzen wir sehen uns gleich und
willkommen zum abend erst nicht denkt
euch vielleicht moment warum sie der
anlass aus naja es ist mal wieder kein
klassisches abendessen sondern eine
cheesecake ein new york cheesecake der
könig aller kuchen ich freue mich darauf
ihn zuzubereiten
den hatte er sich von mir gewünscht und
ich kann das sehr gut nachvollziehen es
ist einfach wirklich mit der geilste
kuchen denn es gibt ja mehr kekse
butterkekse und die machen wir kaputt
die können nach wie vor ein bisschen
feiner seien deshalb werde ich einfach
mal ein bisschen
manchen fällt da einfach kreativ das
jetzt mini blumenkübel ich habe mich
auch nicht so was wie im mörser und
macht euch solange ich dazu geht mit 45
gramm zucker ein wenig muskatnuss und da
die schnellsten wir 70 gramm butter dann
könnt ihr das alles hier auch schon
schön vermischen und so wird als jetzt
geschmolzen und wir hören sie mit runter
so sieht aggressiv
ich habe mir noch ein bisschen butter
drin die nutzen wir um die springform
einzufinden und dann gehen wir einfach
unsere gesamte branche ich fange jetzt
hält diese plattform einfach nicht habt
ihr drei mal benutzt also na ja da muss
der kriegszeit das ganze regelt den
geben wir auf dem boden aber komplett
rein und dann drücken wir es auch schon
ebenmäßig an so sehr schön und so geben
wir das ganze jetzt einfach für neun
minuten in den ofen
ach so bei 175 grad so acht minuten sind
vorbei ich hole jetzt den boden heraus
und stelle ihnen zum abkühlen muss
wirklich komplett kühl sein auf den
balkon und wir kommen zum topping leute
das was ihr seht ist frischkäse das ist
ein kilogramm
wir fügen das ganze jetzt in unsere
schlüssel und in frischkäse lasse ich
jetzt einfach mal kurz auf rühren
während ich bin recht vorbereitet den
ganzen fügen wir jetzt 300 gramm zucker
hinzu
dann will ich nur darüber lachen weil
die skepsis zum gewinn weiter alles
zusammen würden jetzt brauchen wir fünf
eier und von unseren fünf mal brauchen
wir nur das eigelb jetzt schmeißen wir
die rührmaschine wieder an und geben
dafür alles hinzu wenn das schön
vermischt ist 75 milliliter sahne und
eine halbe packung creme fraiche dann
sehen wir weiter
drei teelöffel vanille extrakt und drei
esslöffel speisestärke download jetzt
ist das ganze auch fertig wir haben hier
unsere springform jetzt nehmen wir uns
haben
das hat mir nämlich einen wasserkrug
dann können wir uns auch schon unsere
masse nehmen und die füllen wir jetzt
vorsichtig auf unseren
mit außenrum schützen jetzt wasser und
so gehen wir das ganze jetzt für
eineinhalb stunden bei 160 grad in den
ofen unser respekt ist fertig er hat
oben ein bisschen farbe bekommen das
wollten wir nicht unbedingt die hat sich
jetzt fast gesetzt ist in der mitte noch
ein bisschen wackelig der fällt aber
wieder ein und zwar lassen wir den jetzt
eben mit im wasserbad stehen für 45
minuten bei angelehnt hat für da ist er
leute unsere cheesecake guckt euch mal
annähernd obendrauf ein bisschen bohlen
bekommt finde ich eigentlich sogar sehr
nice wir kümmern uns jetzt aber noch um
die spezialität sind hopping wir haben
hier erdbeere da schneiden wir den
sprung bist du aufgeregt warum du wirst
es gleich sehen jetzt fragen sich
vielleicht warum nimmt dieser mann
gute frage die wir hier erst mal die
erdbeer wir geben jetzt mal unsere
erdbeeren in unseren beschichtete pfanne
und ich weiß was du tun willst ich habe
so eigentlich egal ja ich weiß sehr sehr
klar zweifel
das wird so flüssig oder prozentig
richtig ja ich sage mal ganz ehrlich was
zum besuch der welt möglich das ist die
5 sterne hotels gehen mir ordentlich
zucker darüber machen was passiert so
einer kleinen instant marmelade dann
gehen wir dazu dass das ein bisschen
gleichmäßiger karamellisiert sowie einen
kleinen schluck wasser
wolfgang koller
das wird jetzt hier riecht es einmal
komplett blamiert haben wir den sagt
einmal abgeben jetzt zum sagt noch von
den erdbeeren sicherlich richtig gut
schneiden jetzt an dich aus unserer
gucken wo ich habe da so rudolf körper
rassist lecker aber ich muss sagen ich
will eigentlich den rechten für dessen
frau wir waren ja auch das große finale
es ist unser abendessen heute so gar
nicht erst mal klingt so einfach zu
schön um ihn zu essen also du hast echt
geschafft so habt ihr gesamtes zur
sanften also richtig so und niemand das
paar wolken reinbeißen würdest du siehst
wie sacher bekommen das geht einfach
derzeit geht der mobil rücken wollten
würde ich wollte mich ob abgestellt war
wenig sagte er ich als ist wirklich
super luxus das ist wirklich
konsequenzen blasen der würde
ausverkauft sein ich hier wirkt dafür
eine elf von sie ist so gut ist dann ist
mir das lieber das gefühl ich hier
meister 1
ist er geht auf dem mond bis ich mich
niemals zu suchen so wolter forever
teilchen damit ein paar leute was war
das für ein erfolg heute durch wir haben
uns gesteigert und beim gesamten bedarf
das war wirklich ein gebührendes
abendessen dem bundesfinale meint jetzt
einfach münstertal egger ich bin ich
topspielerinnen stolz und fielen dann
ist das natürlich sehr gerne hat mir
großen spaß gemacht mit den nächsten
wochen habe baywa in ihrem video
für mich kommt das unbedingt auch an da
gab es denn hier überlassen hat und ich
würde noch die nächsten tagen mit diesem
tabu